[Music]
welcome everyone to law and crime daily
i'm brian buckmeyer
co-host terry austin is on assignment
covering the trial of zachary wester
where the prosecution has rested in the
trial of a former deputy accused of
planting drugs on
unsuspecting motors terry explains
zachary wester is facing 67 charges
including racketeering
possession of a controlled substance and
false imprisonment
the charges are related to allegations
of planting drugs while he was out on
patrol
and for one florida motorist it was a
traffic stop
that changed his life we wish you a
merry christmas we wish you merry
christmas
this is former jackson county florida
sheriff deputy
zachary wester as he searches the car of
james
fears i mean i want to home a tune in
case something ever goes in front of the
jury you know
wester reportedly stopped fears while
his wife was driving
on june 4th 2018 for a problem with
their license plate tag
what we got there my friend look at
there
all right both yards can be detained at
this time okay
i can undetain you i just can't unarrest
you wester places james and jade fierce
into handcuffs the deputies explain they
found dope
in their vehicle have you ever seen
anything like that in your car
no sir had you put anything back behind
that front
um the front passenger seat no sir
fears admitted on the stand he was
convicted of four felonies
he knew both wester and fellow deputy
trevor lee
from prior encounters fears was arrested
for possession of meth
but weeks later prosecutors dropped the
charge
saying the case could not be proven
beyond a reasonable doubt
on cross-examination fears told the
defense that he didn't see
either deputy plant anything in his car
do you have a
civil suit pending in this action yes
sir okay
and you sued zachary wester
yes sir and trevor lee
no sir no sir just zachary wester yes
sir
anybody else sheriff's department your
department on redirect
fears explain why he's suing wester
and the sheriff's department because i
sold every damn thing i had to keep my
roof over my head
i sold everything i had that was worth
anything
you told the deputy on that video
that you were going to lose your job
over this and that you felt it was wrong
correct
yes sir you still feel that way did you
seem like this was wrong
yes sir it is wrong wester has pleaded
not guilty
and his defense attorney says he will
take the stand
when they present their case for law and
crime daily
i'm terry austin thanks terry
joining us today is trial attorney jamie
white along with the host of the newest
podcast
on the law and crime network cocktails
tulsa police lieutenant sean larkin now
jamie the defense is going to recall one
of the witnesses
and two officers and actually anticipate
wester to testify
what kind of defense could we be looking
at here
it's gonna be a circus brian uh you know
it's very un
usual it's very unusual that a defendant
testifies
in his own defense and here i can't
think of anything that mr wester can't
say that is going to assist him
you know they found an extraordinary
amount of paraphernalia in the back of
his police car
that could have only been used to assist
in
these unbelievable crimes um
so you know i i suspect they're the it's
a hail mary to find some sympathy in the
jury they only need one or two people
to find that you know he's a nice guy
and
maybe a perverted point of view was
doing his job and therefore
doesn't deserve to go to prison but um
it's a very bad
choice in my opinion i'm part of the
defense council now
sean i'm seeing a lot of the prosecution
using uh
i think i think the best way to say is
juxtaposing wester
who they identify as a bad cop with good
cops like yourself
and trying to really drive home the
emotional impact of saying like this is
the one we have to go after do you think
that's a smart tactic
by the prosecution of showing this is
the bad apple to try to remove from the
tree that is
law enforcement sure it is because i
think the overwhelming
uh you know number of people in the
public they know police overall
are good hard-working guys that just
want to keep these communities safe
and i can tell you there's nobody that
wants a dirty cop gone
more than the good cops that are out
there and so by
portraying you know showing this guy is
the bad apple hey
this other unit investigated them or
this group invested he and
investigated them they themselves want
to get him out of here i think it's a
great tactic
yeah i think it's working out very well
we're looking at a lot of our chatters
on the
on youtube at law and crime commenting
on just that and sean
thanks for joining us because you've
brought a sneak peek from one of your
upcoming podcasts
and this story really moves me let's
take a listen
to this interview with a 91 year old
police officer in arkansas
and you can tell us more on the other
side
well as long as you've been on the job i
assume you get a lot of respect don't
you sir
yes sir if you pull somebody over they
get out of the car
come back grab the ticket and then get
back in the car and drive off don't
say
most people know me when i stop them
it's a bug shot
you know i know everybody
from maybe
five years old up
i helped a lot of people
sean that was a great interview and i
actually saw one of your
episodes really interesting i'm a little
jealous cause i can see in the
background there that you actually
get to share a drink with some of your
guests you got to tell me how you got
dan to agree to that
but tell us more about this officer
who's not planning on retiring anytime
soon
yeah so buckshot he is actually uh as of
yesterday
92 years old so we did the podcast
yesterday with him we kind of got to
have a a celebratory drink
he himself does not drink but we had one
in his honor
um but yeah he's been in law enforcement
this is his 57th year now he did 46
years with the sheriff's department he
retired and was gone for about five
months and he just missed it that much
that he then got hired by the local
police department and he is on his 11th
year there now
and just as he was talking about he
pretty much knows everybody
in that community um you know from from
five-year-olds on up to full-grown
adults and he's kind of a celebrity
in that area because he's been there so
long absolutely now
sean you may be retiring before officer
smith but you still have plans to serve
your community
tell us a little bit about your plans
after retirement yes sir yeah i'm
actually proud to say tomorrow is my
last day on the job here in tulsa
about a 25-year career here kind of
scared but i'm looking forward to some
of the new stuff going forward
just as we talked about the podcast is
something i'm really excited about you
know the name is cocktails i kind of
unofficially call
it cocktails and cocktails and my
co-host who you saw there is howard doss
he's a nice eu
nurse um the two of us are big bourbon
collectors
and so the idea behind each show is
going to be a casual conversation about
a serious profession
the two of us are going to sit down and
talk with police officers
informants convicted felons pretty much
anybody
that's touched the law enforcement world
through the years and just try to talk
to them about their story
but done in this casual conversation
while we're having a drink
um got a book coming out next month that
i've also partnered with dan abrams on
really excited about that called
breaking blue and
i'm actually going to volunteer and work
with a cold case unit here in tulsa
oklahoma
that kind of looks into some of the
older unsolved homicide cases
well sean if you ever need a public
defender woodford reserve is my drink
thank you very much for joining us i've
got you buddy
all right still ahead on law and crime
daily the perfect expert weighs in on
the case of the missing tiger in texas
but first the shocking allegations
defense attorneys for the three former
police officers charged
in the death of george floyd are making
against the government why are their
trials now delayed
next
[Music]
you